[MUSIC PLAYING]
DRUVA REDDY TIRUVURU:
Thank you so
much for taking your time for
attending this session, where
we'll be talking about how we
automated the medical coverage
analysis using Cloud Vision
API and Google Cloud Machine
Learning Engine.
I'm Druva Reddy Tiruvuru.
I'm a cloud data
engineer at Pluto7.
We are a Google Cloud
premier partner.
And alongside with
me on the stage
I have Allison and Joanne.
Do you want to quickly
introduce yourselves?
ALLISON ORECHWA: Sure.
Hi, I'm Allison Orechwa.
I'm in research administration
at the University of Southern
California.
JOANNE PAK: Hi.
I'm Joanne Pak.
And I'm also at USC.
I do coverage analysis.
DRUVA REDDY TIRUVURU: Very good.
Without further ado, let me
pull up today's session outline.
After a brief introduction
of Pluto7 and USC,
Allison will be covering the
goals of research enterprise,
followed by Joanne.
She'll be covering medical
coverage analysis workflow.
And then we'll tackle
the meat of the matter
behind how we automated
the medical coverage
analysis at USC.
And then we'll open
up for Q&A. If you
have any specific
questions, feel
free to drop by after the
talk and get it clarified.
So Pluto7, we are a key
partner for implementation
of artificial
intelligence and machine
learning at Google Cloud.
We bring AI and ML
implementation to the customers
who either do not have the
staff, know-how, the department
or if they need any extended
hands, we dive in as a team.
We understand their
use case, what
they're trying to achieve,
and look at their data
to see if it's achievable.
And then we work in
tandem with the customers
throughout the journey of
their machine learning,
right from the project
kickoff to the production.
And similarly, we
went to USC, where
we demonstrated by providing
a solution to the USC showing
them how we can leverage
machine learning
and AI to automate
medical coverage analysis.
Over to you, Allison.
ALLISON ORECHWA: Thank you.
Thank you, Druva, and thanks to
Google Cloud for inviting us.
So as you probably
know, the University
of Southern California is
a large private university
and academic medical
center located
in Los Angeles, California.
We have strong research
programs in many clinical areas,
such as cancer, biomedical
imaging, neurosciences,
stem cells, and many more.
And collectively,
our researchers
conduct at least 20--
sorry, 200 clinical
trials per year.
And those clinical
trials, the goal of them
are to basically better
understand diseases, as well as
create new therapies and new
standards of care for patients.
So our Clinical and
Translational Sciences
Institute, where
I'm from, is charged
with improving and enhancing
the research pipeline
to get more treatments to
more patients more quickly.
And given our local
population in LA,
we bring special expertise
in diverse populations,
engaging diverse people
in clinical research,
and we bring that expertise
to our larger national network
of institutes like ours.
And that's important because,
when you test a treatment just
with one segment
of the population,
you don't know how well
that treatment will
work for everybody else.
So we aim to correct that by
bringing in more Los Angelenos
into clinical research, and also
trying to enhance the research
efficiency for all studies.
So two years ago, we
surveyed researchers at USC.
And many people complained
about different administrative
processes burdens, like too much
paperwork, too many systems,
long approval times and
unclear requirements.
And it's true.
We were able to measure it,
and in the long lifecycle
of a single clinical
trial, from coming up
with the idea to
publishing the results,
there is a long
pause in the middle.
And it's not actual
science that's
going on during this pause.
The pause is for
approvals and logistics.
They're important things, of
course, like ethics committees
to make sure that the
patients are undergoing
something that's safe.
They're setting up
pharmacy orders,
and they're negotiating
contracts and budgets
with the pharmaceutical
companies or other sponsors who
are paying for the study.
And so this activation process
within the red circles,
that takes about 10 to 20 people
at least 80 hours per study
to complete, with lots of
back-and-forth and long
response times.
So even though
it's 80 man hours,
it can take up to three
months, on average.
And so that translates into a
delay in getting the treatments
to patients.
So we decided it's
time to change.
We embarked on a process
improvement initiative
to make the entire activation
process faster and more
streamlined and more transparent
for the research teams at USC.
Our scope was studies that
use hospital resources, where
the study-related
costs had to be
distinguished and separated
from the regular clinical care
costs.
And we decided to take a lean
process improvement approach.
And to do that, we worked with
a partner in the USC Marshall
School of Business who runs the
Global Center for Supply Chain
Management.
And our thinking there was that,
if his center could improve
quality and speed
in manufacturing,
it could probably
work for research.
So we formed these working
groups and we got to work.
And this was quite a culture
shift because, as you may know,
speed is not exactly
the number one priority
in academic administration.
But the exercise of
looking step by step
in everybody's
individual processes
compared to all the
other offices involved
in the whole activation
process, that
exercise of mapping
the workflow really
helped us see the
duplication that exists
and the redundancies.
It helped us identify these
bottlenecks and the friction
points, which we termed
opportunities for improvement.
And then we took a step back
and we tried to, together,
create an ideal
future state workflow,
and started to implement
those improvements.
And this is too small
to read, of course,
but this diagram
should just give you
a sense of how complex the
research activation process is.
And that's the
future state diagram.
So fast forward a couple
years, by last year
we had implemented
over a quarter
of the steps, which is
a big reduction in waste
and duplication.
And it was just small,
incremental improvements,
by cutting out a
step here and there
and introducing new processes.
And we have made the majority
of the changes in real life,
and the outcome has been
faster approvals for studies.
So the average has dropped from
about 80 to around 60 days.
And we think another outcome is
a happier researcher community.
So we surveyed the
research community again,
and they said the
process has become
easier and less frustrating.
But we know we have more
to do, so in the spirit
of continuous
improvement, we wanted
to keep the momentum going.
And we knew we
had an opportunity
to really improve further
with exponential technology.
So we turned to Google Cloud
and machine learning and AI.
And with the help
of Pluto7, we were
able to see the potential of
using those technologies in one
piece of the process.
So using a proof of concept
project with Pluto7,
we applied ML and AI to the part
of the budgeting process that's
called Medicare
coverage analysis.
And I'll now turn it over to our
MCA expert at USC, Joanne Pak.
JOANNE PAK: So MCA is
Medicare coverage analysis.
And so basically,
this is our workflow.
This is not just for
USC, but this is usually
what happens in
other academic sites.
So Medicare coverage
analysis, basically what we do
is we look at the studies
and look at the services
that we have to do,
tests and procedures,
and determine if it will
be covered by Medicare.
So as it says Medicare
coverage analysis,
is this going to be
covered by Medicare?
So in 2000, the
Clinton administration
instituted a clinical
trial policy.
Basically, what it
is is that if it
is a qualified clinical trial,
certain items and services
can be billed to the insurance,
even though it's doing inside
of the clinical trial.
So with that, in all
the research that we do,
we perform Medicare
coverage analysis.
And this is just a small part
of the whole research process
that Allison was talking about.
And this is where Pluto7
and USC partner took over,
and perhaps that we can
bring machine learning
and AI to streamline and reduce
the time they were spending.
So the process is that we
receive a protocol document,
meaning that's the
study document where
it has study design
and objectives
and what we need to do, what
we are trying to accomplish
through this clinical trial,
and who's going to do what
and what needs to be done.
So it's usually a PDF document.
We receive it.
And a coverage
analyst, like myself,
will review the protocol.
And protocols are
usually pretty thick,
and there are a lot of
scientific language.
But what main thing
that we look at
is what's called study calendar,
something that looks like this.
This is just off
from a protocol.
Set a calendar, schedule
event, we call it.
It shows on the left
side what things it needs
to be done at what time point.
So this is just from a
protocol that's out there.
And so, we review the study
calendar, which is in PDF form.
And, in order for us to do
coverage analysis, at USC,
we use something called Encore.
It's a CTMS Clinical
Trial Management System--
it's a software.
We use we do
everything in Encore.
However, in many
institutions, if they're not
using Encore or
CTMS, they choose
to do it in Excel spreadsheet.
So, basically, if we
didn't have Encore,
as a person what I had to
do is to read the protocol
and look at this page
and then create--
basically copy and
paste manually.
So I'm typing everything
on the left side
and then creating all the
columns and putting all the Xs.
Xs Just mean it's
happening at this point.
So, that's the first
step-- basically creating
an Excel version for all
this that is to be done.
At this point, I'm not doing any
analysis, I'm just copying it.
And this is where
Pluto7 came in,
and they were able to extract
this information into Excel
spreadsheet by
machine-learning and AI.
And Druva is going to
explain the details
of a technicality of that.
So, once that's done,
what we do first
is we have to find out if it's
a qualified clinical trial--
QCT stands for Qualified
Clinical Trial.
So qualified clinical
trials are a set
of questions that
we have to answer.
There are a few
questions answered,
but what's most important is
the three questions that all
have to be answered, yes.
The first one is, does this--
we call it IP--
IP in clinical trials means
investigational product.
So if the drug is
investigational product--
brand new drug--
let's say a company
is developing--
does that fall into
Medicare benefit category?
Medicare benefit
category is just
a list of services
that can be covered
by Medicare-- not clinical
trial just by Medicare.
Like for my mother
who is on Medicare--
when she goes to annual
checkup, that's covered.
And where she needs an eye
exam, that's not covered.
So it's like Medicare
benefit category.
So first, we say, does this
help in the Medicare benefit
category?
And, if it is a drug, it's
usually a drug and biologicals,
so I say, yes.
And the next question
is, does this study
have a therapeutic intent?
Meaning, is this that it
going to somehow bring
quality of life or extend--
create some type of a treatment.
And not just the collecting
data, not just to
see if it has a toxicity--
so does it have a
therapeutic intent?
Yes.
And then, next question is,
does this diagnose disease?
So, meaning, the study have
toward their breast cancer
patients or a pulmonary disease.
So if it is, yes,
all three questions
have to be answered, yes.
And once this is
answered, yes, then there
is a fourth question
that has to be
answered that's deemed trial.
So, if it is a study, it's
funded by government--
National Institute of Health
or Department of Defense
or any government
agency funding it--
It's automatically deemed.
Or does it have IND--
investigational new drug--
application filed to FDA?
So, these are the
type of questions
we go through in QCT checklist.
And then once it says
it's a qualifying trial--
it's a yes or no-- and
the qualifying trial just
means that if there are
items and services being done
in the trial, even though
it's doing only for the study,
it can be billed
to the Medicare.
If it does not qualify, those
investigational items cannot be
billed to insurance.
So, for example-- if
I'm in a clinical trial,
I'm unhealthy subject--
and I'm on this clinical
trial, and if I'm not
on a clinical
trial, I'll just go
to see my doctor once a year.
That can be billed to Medicare.
But if I'm a clinical
trial and they
want to see me every month--
they want to draw blood--
that's something
that's not going
to be covered by Medicare on a
non-qualified clinical trial.
So that's what we do.
Then that question
drives the next part.
And then what the
next part means
is that when we see this
one, we have to determine,
for example, very
top informed consent.
That's something
I look at and go,
is this considered
research item or what
we call standard of care?
Informed consent
just simply means
that patient is
signing a consent
form that is, I want to
be in this clinical trial.
So, if the patient is
not on a clinical trial,
there's no reason for them
to sign informed consent.
So there'll be research.
But usually if
you go down, let's
say there is a
complete physical exam.
Physical exam is being
done as screening.
And the one below is
abbreviated physical exam
that's being done at
different time points.
So, at this
different time point,
research, meaning something
other than interest
is going to pay for it.
Standard care meaning
it can be billed
to the Medicare and insurance.
So extracting it,
in this example,
we say screening for
the physical exam.
At screening very first
visit, we say research.
But then, you go down and
determine that each one of them
are by the standard
of care research.
So, that's the process of
Medicare coverage analysis.
That analyzes each one of them--
it's not just me just
saying, oh, yeah,
I feel like saying
it's research.
it's standard care.
But, we do go by the national
coverage determination.
There is a government reference
that we have to follow,
or there is a national society
guidelines for cancer trials.
So, we have something
called NCCN guidelines--
National Comprehensive
Cancer Network guidelines--
that tells us, OK, all these
patients in a breast cancer
study to have the image CT
scans done every six months
is something routine.
So, we use that reference point
to make that determination.
So, this whole process takes
from basically somebody
sitting down,
reading the protocol,
extracting it, reading or
finding all the references,
and then making into
this determination.
This is a very lengthy process,
because it's not something
that-- if I don't do
it right, then USC
can be fined, because it's
something that even though I
make maybe a mistake,
but if I did not
do the determination
correctly, if I bill something
to the Medicare incorrectly,
the Medicare what
should be the last
pair, and then I'd say
that you are the first pair.
So, this is our manual
process that we go through.
And then Druva's
going to come and how
the Pluto7 came in
and streamlined while
part of this process
in the streamline.
Thank you.
DRUVA REDDY TIRUVURU: Thank you
so much, Joanne and Allison.
So, this is how it works.
We have clinical
trials protocols
coming in the form of a PDF.
They are stored in
Google Cloud Storage.
Google Cloud Storage is a
RESTful online file system web
service offered by Google
where you can store and access
your data on GCP infrastructure.
And, followed by that,
we have app engine here.
App engine is a
serverless instance.
It's fully managed.
By fully managed, I mean
that the applications
that are deployed on the App
Engine scales automatically.
And you don't have
to worry about
the underlying infrastructure.
All you have to focus
on is your code.
Oh, here, app engine
access choreographer
like a Data Manager.
It follows the data into
the Cloud Vision API.
Cloud Vision API is a pre-built,
machine-learning model
offered by Google, which can be
accessed through RESTful API.
It helps us to enable
and detect the text
present in the clinical trial
protocols and extract it.
And, followed by that, we have
a cloud machine-learning engine,
where we hosted our
one-day convolution
on your intellectual model.
It's serverless
and fully managed.
Or you can also custom
select your resources
that you would like.
And it also offers training
and predicting services
individually or together.
I have kept the doc
high level, but if you
have any specific
questions regarding
the technical details, please
feel free to reach out to me.
Before going to the next
slide, by a show of hands,
how many of you here are data
scientists and data engineers?
Very good.
That's a pretty good number.
Let me talk about the data set.
The data set that we use here
are from two different sources.
One is USC registry that the
historical clinical trial
protocols they had
over the years.
And followed by that, we
had publicly available data
sets that we got from
clinicaltrial.gov.
It's United States
Library of Medicine--
they're offering this.
And we tagged clinical trial
statements extracted from
40,000-plus clinical
trial protocols.
I feel that this data set is
really good as it was written,
the clinical trial terms.
And it's publicly available
in the URL mentioned here.
So, on your left, you
can see a snapshot of one
of the pages of the clinical
trial protocol which
has the study objectives,
primary objectives,
secondary objectives, and so on.
We are passing the
clinical trial protocols
in the form of a PDF into
Cloud Vision API, which
is a pre-built machine-learning
model that I mentioned before.
It has multiple features
like label detection,
logo detection,
face recognition,
handwriting recognition.
But, in this project, we
leverage optical character
recognition feature
of Cloud Vision
API where it could
detect and extract
the text out of the PDFs.
And followed by that,
text pre-processing
is an integral part, an
extremely important step
of machine-learning journey.
We spend a significant
amount of time
there, because the
quality of data
and the amount of information
that you can extract out
of the data is
extremely important,
and it determines the ability
of your quality of the model.
And we spend a
significant amount of time
there in pre-processing.
As part of pre-processing, we
transformed all the statements
that were extracted
by Cloud Vision API
into a sequence of words
separated by a whitespace.
And then we also had to
remove the punctuation,
special characteristics--
characters like
non-alpha numeric symbols
like question marks, or
the Greek signs, et cetera.
And then once we
pre-process the data,
we found that the data
was highly unbalanced.
The data is called unbalanced
when a class of data
has a huge dominance
over the other.
Over here, 70% of the
statements that were extracted
were labeled as research,
like Joanne was mentioning.
Research is something that
Medicare doesn't cover,
whereas standard is.
We had standard
statements to only 30%
of the entire statements
that were extracted.
To overcome that, we
used a random, unbalanced
undersampling.
What does that mean?
We take the classes from
the minority classes
and match it against the
majority so that they are equal
and use the rest of the
classes during validation.
Followed by that,
we did training.
We used an open source
library called FastText.
It's used for text
representation and then text
classification and
workbook representation.
FastText is an
extension of Word2Vec.
It's a predictor model that
uses raw text as input,
and it predicts the word
given its surrounding
in the context and vice versa.
Over here, once we did
the embedded training,
we tested it out using
a very rare word, which
is gastroenteritis.
Thanks to Joanne, this is how
we will work with the customers
to understand their
data, and that's
where their domain
expertise comes in.
It's a very rare data.
And, as you can see,
it could figure out
the corresponding embeddings
for that particular word.
Here, it didn't do when it
appeared in the training data,
but the FastText
embedder training
could figure out
the word endings,
whereas when we tried out
other open source libraries,
it throwed in error, since that
gastroenteritis word wasn't
present in the training calls.
By the way, if
anyone is wondering
what the gastroenteritis
is-- it's a type of a flu.
Joanne helped me to
understand what that is.
So you put FastText word
embedding could also
figure out, it could generate
better word embeddings
for rare words.
And, also, it could
find word embeddings
for the words which are not even
in the part of the vocabulary.
And, as part of the next
step, our text classifier
was trained using
deep neural networks,
with preordained
embeddings that we
built in the previous
steps as inputs
to predict whether or not the
short free text statements that
are extracted using
Cloud Vision API.
This is standard-- or
that means whether it's
covered by Medicare or
it's covered by research.
So, the pre-trained
word embeddings
were used as input for 1D
convolutional neural networks.
And we hosted that onto a Google
Cloud machine-learning engine.
So those three
points are the steps
that we have taken
before deploying
our model on the GCM--
just converting all
the standard sentences
into a data set in the
sequence of word indexes
and reshuffle the
training and test data
sets, and also prepare
an embeddings matrix,
which contain an index I. The
embedding vector for the word
from the index I.
And this is the
overall model where
the input text, which is
pre-processsed and labeled,
is taken and we did an embedding
training of FastText, which
is an extension of Word2Vec.
And then we trained classify
using 1D convolution neural
network.
And we got the predictions
where the particular statement
is research or standard.
So these are all the results.
Our model could predict whether
that statement is research
or standard with 86% accuracy.
And the other advantages of
the model that we have is it's
quick to train on GPU.
So, within 10 to
15 minutes, we were
better able to train
our model and then
we could try out
multiple architectures
within a short amount of time.
And the other one is
UCPR in French time,
once your model
is up and running.
You don't need a GPU,
can do it on CPU,
which is lower cost
compared to GPU.
And third point is you can
train periodically if required.
Consider if a new
set of protocols
comes into their registry and
the guidelines keep changing,
new drugs come in--
so you can keep
your model updated
by retraining it
periodically if necessary.
And so I'll pass
it on to Allison.
ALLISON ORECHWA: Just,
in terms of closing,
from USC's
perspective, we really
felt like this was a successful
proof of concept project.
So, the concept has been proven.
Compared to a human-only
determination process,
this technology really showed
that it could drastically
reduce the time needed for
this part of the processing.
So, we hope that we can extend
the solution beyond breast
cancer and to other
pieces of the whole puzzle
and really make an impact in
the speed of research activation
and other areas of the
research lifecycle.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]